guys welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel and today i'm going to
be reacting
to green dot by nba young boy if you
like these videos and you want to see
more
don't forget to subscribe subscribe
subscribe i want to move out of my
parents house someday
so please subscribe so i can get out
and like and leave a comment on what
video i should do next
[Music]
um
[Music]
so we start off with some gunshots
i don't know why like why why are we
shooting at each other is that just
like normal
[Music]
dumb [ __ ] you know that i'm walking with
it on me i say
then that's when they stepping on your
homie i say stretch them catch me murder
walk and then i bang
pushing next to them i don't know what
you saying
starting off i'm having a hard time like
understanding what he's saying
because just like kind of fast um
but he's like like in the kitchen on the
counter
singing to the camera i don't know why
you know i don't know what's going on
um that's all i got i'm sorry guys
people i'm going to keep i'm going to
keep going who says why i do your asses
like i've done
i don't really understand what's going
on here but what i can see is the man's
got a lot of friends
he's in the kitchen he and he also
seems to have a girlfriend or a love
interest of some sort
i don't know if they're dating i don't
know what the relationship status is
but like honestly i haven't been able to
understand a word
that he's been saying i i'm sorry i'm
sorry i know
baby had to fight in jail in different
past [ __ ] check out [ __ ] with paypal
with certain things
that we stepped on him i wish i could
spit in this casket [ __ ] him i've been
thugging him but now wanting you [ __ ]
okay i heard him saying i wish i could
spit in his casket
so it looks like someone
died and he they were not cool
he said like i don't even care like i'm
gonna spit in your casket why that's a
little disrespectful
i'm like let the dead be dead but you
know i'm not
i'm a different breed you know
[Music]
a little freaked out and now they're
waving the money around i've been saying
this forever why do
get a credit card what do you need cash
for
like i know rich people
like i swear i know rich people and they
don't wave around money
like that's so weird like
it's a different world i guess then
that's when they stepping on your homies
as they stretch them
catch me murder walking then i bang
pushing next to them rip down draw down
on you what you saying
dumb [ __ ] you know that i'm walking with
it on me i say
[Music]
the funniest part is this is like the
most average
kitchen ever they're like waving around
this cash
in the most mediocre kitchen ever like
even the appliances are kind of average
but i feel like
i don't know why i think this but i
think the general mood of the song is
just like i'm really cool
like i i can't understand the thing he
said
but i seriously think that he's just
like
in the kitchen talking about how cool
and like hard he is
he definitely put a part about how he
gets girls like he's just letting the
world know he's got hoes
um and then it just kind of went back to
i'm cool i'm cool because of this i'm
cool because of that
like i i got guns or like i'm hot
you know it's i'm gonna keep going
better [ __ ] walking cocaine
so he was saying that again like why do
we
guys if someone talks [ __ ] about you
just keep on moving
you don't need to like play this like
game
you know um
yeah so that's what i would say like
keep on moving
conflict resolution is like you don't
have to deal with people like that but
apparently
he's saying like he's putting some
threats out there
dumb [ __ ] you know they don't want them
where they don't say stomp them
then that's when they stepping on your
homies they stretch them catch me murder
walking then i bang
pushing next to them rip down draw down
you what you saying
dumb [ __ ] you know that i'm walking with
it on me i say
then that's when they okay i think these
are some threats i think
i think there's some threats in here
because he's saying stop him
so i think that means to like kill him
i just do you like do they have hobbies
like is this what they do
i would say get a hop i'm not i know the
comments are gonna come after me and be
like i don't understand well damn right
i don't understand
like hello i don't
[Music]
they're waving around cash in the most
average house
the most average house
oh shoot i need it okay so
um i'm gonna say this one i like did not
understand what was going on at all
i think like he's basically like saying
don't talk [ __ ] maybe threatening some
people
and i get [ __ ] like that's kind of
what my takeaway was
but i'm sure i missed something if you
enjoyed this video
don't forget to comment like subscribe
please subscribe because i want to move
out of my parents house someday
someday i don't know when but someday oh
and also comment
what video i should do next so the
comment that gets the most likes
i will that'll be the video i do next so
don't forget
comment comment comment i'll talk to you
guys later bye